foreign
Modesto California hi Natalie how are
you
hi thank you for uh taking my call sure
what's up hi
um so
um I am currently on baby step two and
for work I am a federal employee
um because I'm a federal employee and
also the position that I'm in I am
deemed essential
so in a uh in an event of a government
shutdown I would still have to work but
without a paycheck throughout that
during that period of a shutdown
so with that with the recent talks of of
a government shutdown this year which
the taco government shutdown is always
it's always in the year over year but
this time it's actually making me a
little bit nervous so my question is
since I'm on baby step two should I
increase my my starter emergency fund in
case there is a government shutdown
um this year no
no you don't ever increase your baby
step emergency fund what you might do is
you might push pause on the whole dad
gum thing and pile up cash
but just push pause on your whole baby
steps no baby steps at all are involved
it's we have an Emer there's a tornado
coming towards our house and we need an
emergency we need a big pile of money
okay so just don't even stop everything
and pile up cash everywhere if you think
this is going to happen
okay now all right how long have you
been a federal government employee
um this is my second year so I haven't
experienced anything you know when it
comes to the government shutdown since I
joined back and do a little research for
yourself
how many times you've actually been shut
down
yeah hardly ever
yeah hardly ever yeah I think three
times in 30 years or something like that
yeah and the most recent one being in
January of 2019 it's just I'm feeling a
little nervous because
one maybe it's because I'm doing this
debt-free journey into my co-workers are
out are you know making me nervous as
well so they're in talks of you know
raising their emergency fund or they're
saving up money in case they're doing
they're broke people
okay
so what we need to decide what the real
threat is okay so if someone calls me up
and says our company is considering
layoffs
do I stop everything and build up an
emergency fund then the question is what
is the probability you are going to be
laid off
if it's less than if it's 50 50 yeah
stop build up cash if you think there's
a 10 chance you're going to be laid off
this is called worrying
just work your plan and shut up okay so
what do you think the probability is
after doing a little bit of research not
listening to your broke co-workers who
worry about everything but really
looking at it and saying okay in the
current political environment what
things are the same as they were during
the times that the three times it did
get shut down in 30 years or whatever
the number is I don't remember I'm
guessing but it's not far off of that
um and so you know and oh by the way
there's 14 times or 26 times that we
almost did and only three times they did
and so it's usually just a bunch of
hogwash and we keep working
yeah that's my yes yeah and if that if
you think you know okay there's a 10
chance this is gonna happen ah
go with it just just keep working your
plan hey Natalie how much debt do you
have
I currently uh 80 000 right now okay and
are you working a second job
no I work currently with my schedule I'm
currently working seven days a week
and um every six months my base salary
right now is at 57 a thousand here
that's my base salary but with overtime
I'm projected to make about 105 110 this
year okay cool how much overtime are you
doing right now all day long yeah a lot
yeah yeah again every six months our
schedule changes so um I'm like
I'm probably going to have this schedule
for the full year so I'm doing at least
75 hours of
uh working Center and you're not
required to do the overtime if you're if
they shut down
I am required no not overtime
on the factories that I work for so if
the factories are working I work
so they are deemed essential so I'm
essential so I'm most 100 I'll be
working overtime
because that the the reason I'm asking
that is I'm thinking like if for some
crazy scenario the government shut down
if you had a side hustle if you had
another source of income that could be
helpful no margin to do that right but
with 75 hours a week yeah yeah and
before the schedule
um I I had the time but again there's
the six uh our schedule changes from
time to time so I'm taking advantage of
the schedule I have yeah I get that and
you're doing you're working your butt
off girl way to go I'm proud of you yeah
and that's tough and what you're doing
is a lot of hard work too it's not like
it's not wussy work this is real work so
um yeah I you have to decide what you
think the probability
with actual facts not whiners at work
but the actual probability of the
shutdown is and if you think it's 50 50
then I would stop everything in pile up
cash I personally don't think this one
is 50 50.
that's a personal opinion but you can
look at it and say I you know because I
I think what's going on is the jockeying
with a new Republican Congress against a
Democrat Senate and they're trying to
it's a power play the shutdowns usually
are power place by the way but you you
know you've got a president on one side
a senate on that side and then you've
got the Republicans on the other side in
the Congress and so they're gonna
they're gonna push around and act like
they did something and then at the last
minute they're all going to sign up
that that's what they do 99 of the time
but that's just an opinion of from
somebody who has no respect for hardly
any of those people up there so Dave I
think we just need you to go to
Washington
we need you to run their budget there
would be a war we need you to teach them
how to build a war you don't want me up
there how are we running our country at
a deficit like we're we're not doing a
zero-based budget we're doing we need a
no spend month yes we do in the Congress
come on let's go well then Sarah would
be back off overtime
or Natalie rather I'm sorry oh my
goodness sorry about that Natalie hey
you'll be okay kiddo I think you're okay
but you look at it and you make the
Judgment don't stop your plan based on
worries because worries are always there
but if the facts are scary
then you would stop your plan and pile
up cash that's the moral of the story
for all of you facing these kinds of
things